hallo zusammen wie immer herzlich willkommen zu unserer
kurzen einführung
für unsere heutige sitzung also
lassen sie uns zuerst einen
kurzen rückblick auf unsere letzte
sitzung werfen sie alle kennen diesen typen hier das ist robert rifus er wurde weltberühmt
als der erste, der gegen ein
ihs-programm verlor  obwohl er
interessante bücher über die grenzen von ai geschrieben hat
und in unserer letzten sitzung und hier ist der
link zu dieser sitzung auf youtube haben wir
seinen ansatz künstlicher
neuronaler netze und auch den symbolischen
ansatz
und die sehr interessanten
beziehungen diskutiert, die er
zu
wirklich wichtigen philosophen wie zb  Wie
der verstorbene Wittgenstein und auch Martin
Heidegger sehen
wir, dass
Hubert
Trifos große Anstrengungen unternommen hat, um die
Wissenschaft der künstlichen Intelligenz mit
der Philosophiegeschichte zu verbinden und auch
die Lücken zwischen
Technologiephilosophie und
Philosophiegeschichte zu schließen. Ich denke, das ist eine wirklich
interessante Aufgabe
und heute  wir werden
zu einem neueren
übergehen, ich sage nicht philosoph, sondern vielleicht
sci  Vertreter der Verhaltensforscher, ein
Hirnforscher, nämlich Paul Smolinski,
der noch lebt, und seinen sehr berühmten
Artikel
über die richtige Behandlung von Konnektionismus
und um besser zu verstehen, was
Konnektionismus bedeutet, und auch darüber, wie die
Turing-Maschine und
andere Maschinen funktionieren, zum Beispiel neuronale
Netze
ich übergebe an ano arno, der uns jetzt
demonstrieren wird
, wie sie funktionieren, wie solche
maschinen
funktionieren und wie sie mit unserem
heutigen thema zusammenhängen,
also hallo, ich hoffe, du hörst mich und du siehst
mein
firefox-fenster,
willkommen nochmal, ähm,
ich bin  Ich versuche
ein wenig zu veranschaulichen, was hinter
den theoretischen Diskussionen steckt,
die wir in der letzten Woche hatten und die
wir heute haben werden,
wenn Sie sich an Sauls Text
und seine Diskussion darüber erinnern,
wie wir eine Maschine intelligent nennen könnten,
und an sein Argument, dass keine Maschine  kann
intelligent sein, wenn es einem Programm folgt.
Wenn Sie sich an diese Art der Argumentation erinnern, kennen
Sie auch
die spezifische Definition
eines Programms  die spezifische definition eines
algorithmus und die spezifische definition
eines digitalen computer, die
von sir vorausgesetzt wurde
und dieser grundgedanke wurde durch das
turing in nicht berechenbaren
zahlen eingeführt
und stand auch im hintergrund des
klassischen symbolischen ansatzes von ai
this is a  zwar ein etwas komplizierterer
Zusammenhang, aber
die allgemeine Diskussion ging
beispielsweise auch im früheren Buch von
uber drifus davon aus,
dass ein digitaler Computer im Grunde so
etwas wie eine Drehmaschine ist
und das bedeutet, dass
der digitale Computer
auf der Ebene seiner
Funktionalität besteht, sagen wir mal
nicht  auf der ebene seiner
hardware besteht er aus so
etwas wie einem prozessor, einem lese- und einem
schreibkopf, einem speicher und einer tabelle mit
anweisungen, wie es turing oder
ein programm genannt wird,
und ich wollte sie nur an dieses
sehr spezifische verständnis
eines digitalen computer erinnern, das ist  Bis heute ist er
sehr wichtig
und definiert zum Beispiel mehr oder weniger,
was ein Algorithmus ist,
also wollte ich nur  Um Ihnen ein sehr
konkretes Beispiel einer Turing-Maschine zu zeigen
, die so programmiert ist
, dass sie testet,
ob eine bestimmte Zahl ein Palindrom ist
, dh ob eine bestimmte Binärzahl
in beide Richtungen gelesen werden kann und es
sich um dieselbe Zahl handelt,
also in diesem Fall die Turing-Maschine
tut genau das, um zu testen, ob es ein
Palindrom ist, also haben wir ein Programm,
das in einer etwas komplizierten
Syntax geschrieben ist, aber im Grunde ist es sehr einfach,
wir können eine Eingabe hochladen und in diesem Fall wird
die Eingabe einfach in den
Speicher geschrieben und  dann können wir das programm starten
und dann wirst du sehen was passiert
es löscht zuerst die erste ziffer
scrollt die ganze
zahlenfolge bis zum ende durch prüft ob
am ende der reihe das gleiche ticket steht
und dann macht es das in
beiden  Richtungen
bis er schließlich keine
weitere Zahl mehr findet und
dann ähm
produziert er die Ausgabe und das heißt hier
wird angenommen das war eigentlich
ähm
binäres Palindrom ich ändere jetzt die Eingabe
und dann sho  uld
sollte ein anderes Ergebnis haben, weil
wir in diesem Fall kein Palindrom haben.
Warum zeige
ich das, sehen Sie hier, es stoppt, sobald es
am Anfang
und am Ende der Reihe von Binärziffern einige äh nicht dieselben Zahlen findet
warum zeige ich das noch einmal,
weil es deutlich macht, dass der digitale
computer
hier auf der operation von symbolen basiert
die operationen werden durch regeln definiert
die regeln werden von einem programmierer vorgegeben
und der programmierer muss eine idee haben
wie er die aufgabe theoretisch lösen kann
damit jemand  hier
hatte eine Idee, was eine binäre Ziffer ist,
was ein binäres Palindrom ist, er hatte eine
Idee, wie man
einen Test einer binären
Palmendrohne löst  Überprüfen Sie am anderen Ende erneut, ob
dies die gleiche Nummer ist, und so weiter und
so weiter. Im Grunde definiert also das theoretische
Verständnis eines Menschen
einen Algorithmus, und dieser Algorithmus
wird in einem Programm, einer
Anweisungstabelle, implementiert  s, die ausgeführt wird und
nichts anderes tut, als
Symbole zu manipulieren
In erster Linie
erinnern die Regeln an die Wichtigkeit von
Regeln, die Wichtigkeit
der Manipulation von
Symbolen und so weiter und so weiter, und China
ist ein
Regelgedankenexperiment, und es stand auch im Mittelpunkt von Uber Trifus früherer Kritik an ai,
aber im Text von 1988 von um  von uber
trifuse, dass wir letzte Woche diskutiert
haben, tauchte ein neues Paradigma auf, wie er es nannte,
weil
[Music
] sehr viel mit KI-Forschung in Kontakt stand
und Sie beobachteten, dass etwas
Neues passierte
,
beispielsweise in den 50er und 50er Jahren im Zusammenhang mit dem Namen Rosenplat Frank Rosenblood
das Perzeptron
und diese Art von
Ansatz wird
sehr oft als konnektionistischer Ansatz bezeichnet,
wie im Fall von Smolinskis Text
beginnt wi  Eine andere Art von Grunddenken
oder Grundgedanken ist
die Idee hier zu sagen, okay,
wir wissen zumindest einige Dinge über
das System, das denkt, nämlich das Gehirn,
und wir versuchen, eine Maschine zu konstruieren
, die dem Gehirn ähnlich ist,
sodass
das Gehirn aus einzelnen besteht  Prozessoren,
die Neuronen genannt werden, sind miteinander verbunden,
und
jedes
Signal, das in diese Art von Gehirn eingegeben
wird, wird durch
Signale durch Neuronen und ihre vielen, vielen
Neuronen und die spezifischen Verbindungen
zwischen diesen Neuronen verarbeitet,
und es ist tatsächlich diese Art von Ansatz
, diese Art von grundlegendem Gedanken  definiert
die Wahrnehmung und das definiert, was
man heute künstliche neuronale Netze nennt,
und das ist, sagen wir mal, eine Art Maschine
, um das Wort des Leids zu sprechen, die
anders funktioniert,
ähm, einen Moment,
also
ah
, tut es nicht, es hat nicht geholfen, also entschuldigen Sie mich
ähm
, wie funktioniert diese Maschine jetzt,
dieses künstliche neuronale Netzwerk,
für einige von Ihnen wird es banal sein, aber ich
denke, für einige von Ihnen wird es
möglicherweise hilfreich sein, um Sie zu unterstützen  Verstehen Sie die
ganze Diskussion
hier Wir beginnen nicht mit einem theoretischen
Verständnis des Problems Wir
verstehen es nicht Wir beginnen nicht mit einer
Regel Wir beginnen nicht mit Symbolen,
die auf der Grundlage von Regeln manipuliert werden
Hier
beginnen wir mit  Eine Maschine, die Signale
an ihrem Eingang hat. Ich hoffe, Sie sehen meinen Cursor, also haben
wir Eingang 1 und Eingang 2,
und Sie haben Verbindungen
und einzelne Prozessoren.
Diese einzelnen Prozessoren haben unterschiedliche
Eingänge, und diese Eingänge
werden in einer Art Funktion hinzugefügt
und erzeugen a  weitere Ausgabe,
die durch Verknüpfungen zu weiteren
Signalprozessen weitergegeben wird,
also was hier passiert,
Sie haben zuerst eine Eingabe
, die die Eingabe des einzelnen
Prozessors n1 definiert. Dies ist das gleiche für den
Prozessor n2 und das gleiche für den
Prozessor und drei,
jetzt haben Sie die Ausgaben  von n1 und 2 und
m3
und kann diese Ausgänge in den
Eingang von n4 einspeisen
und so weiter und so weiter,
so dass das Signal des
Eingangs durch alle Verbindungen in
allen Einzelprozessen o verarbeitet wird  Wenn dieses
Netzwerk schließlich
hier zwei Ausgänge definiert, ist
die Grundidee sehr einfach,
und
was eine solche Maschine tun kann,
hängt sicherlich stark von der Struktur der
Links ab,
es hängt von den Aktivierungsfunktionen ab,
den Funktionen, die von jedem einzelnen verarbeitet werden
Prozessor
oder künstliches Neuronal, wenn Sie es so nennen wollen,
und
was am wichtigsten ist,
sind die sogenannten Gewichte,
und die Gewichte sind
[Musik]
reelle Zahlen oder im Fall der
Computer-Gleitkommazahlen
, die
mit jeder Verbindung zwischen verknüpft sind  zwei
einzelne Prozessoren also w1 w2
das sind Fließkommazahlen,
die die Bedeutung sagen wir
dieser Eingabe in Bezug auf diese einzelnen
Prozesse
[Musik] definieren
und deshalb gibt es,
wenn
Sie auf die
Berechnungsebene gehen, werden sie
mit den verschiedenen Eingaben der multipliziert  Signalprozessoren
ja, was hier passiert, ist,
dass die Beziehung zwischen Eingang und
Ausgang
ist, wenn Sie die Struktur
des Netzwerks und der Aktivati
setzen  In jedem einzelnen Prozess funktioniert,
dass das Verhältnis von Input zu Output im
Wesentlichen durch die Gewichte der
Verknüpfungen
definiert wird, also definieren die Gewichte,
was der Output zu einem bestimmten Input ist
oder anders gesagt,
was im Fall der Turing-
Maschine
das Programm
ist  definiert,
was die Maschine tut
, welche Art von Ausgangseingabe zu
welcher Art von Ausgabe erzeugt wird.
Dieses Programm ist hier.
Wenn es ein Programm gibt,
das in den Gewichten
auf viele verschiedene Arten gefunden wird, ist
dies ein sehr einzelnes, ein einfaches
künstliches neuronales Netzwerk
und das nächste, um das es geht  Milliarden
von Gewichtsparametern und diese
Gewichte definieren, was diese Maschine tut.
Nein,
das ist wichtig zu wissen, weil diese
Gewichte nicht durch Regeln oder ähnliches definiert werden.
Sie sind nur Zahlen, ein Haufen Zahlen
und ein riesiger Haufen Zahlen,
und das ist wichtig  wissen, dass dies nicht der Fall ist.
Diese sind nicht direkt zumindest
nicht prima facie mit Wurzeln identifizierbar
und zweitens manipulieren sie keine
Symbole oder ähnliches  s ist
mehr
die verarbeitung von signalen es sind
zahlen die hier berechnet werden man setzt
sowas wie ein symbol oder
so oder einfach nicht voraus, denn es stimmt oder
so was das sind nur
gleitkommazahlen
die
im grunde was berechnet werden  ist schließlich die
Matrixmultiplikation,
also ist dies eine ganz andere Art von
Maschine,
und was damit verbunden ist, ist am
wichtigsten, dass die
Verbindung zu der Frage, woher
die Gewichte kommen
, sicher ist, dass Sie Gewichte so eingeben können,
wie Sie es für sinnvoll halten
Sie könnten versuchen, diese Maschine zu programmieren,
indem Sie einfach die Gewichte variieren,
aber das wäre selbst in einem kleinen
künstlichen neuronalen Netzwerk
ein Problem, denke ich,
und es wäre in
riesigen neuronalen Netzwerken völlig unmöglich,
so dass
der Erfolg dieser Art von künstlichen
Maschinen damit verbunden ist  Der Ansatz
, der bereits in Triforce des Lernens besprochen wurde
, ist, was wir tun, was wir tatsächlich tun, wir trainieren
diese Systeme
und Training bedeutet h  Hier
passen wir die Gewichte so an, dass
das System endlich mehr oder weniger so funktioniert, wie
wir es uns jetzt vorstellen. Also, was wir hier
am Anfang tun, wir haben
normalerweise einige Gewichte, wir setzen sie zufällig
und dann haben wir einige Daten, von denen wir
wissen, was das Ergebnis sein soll, also
wissen wir, dass wir Input 1 Input 2 haben wollen und
es sollte mit einem Output eins und
o eins und oder o zwei enden,
damit wir das Signal verarbeiten und dann
den Fehler berechnen können
und was wir dann tun  ist, wir passen die
Kette
, die wartet
, so an, dass
es hoffentlich besser wird,
und das
beginnt am Ende und geht
zurück zum
Eingangspegel,
und deshalb heißt
die eine Richtung
Signalausbreitung und dies ist
Rückausbreitung von  der fehler
und diese
generelle methode der backpropagation wurde
mehr oder weniger erst in den 80er jahren etabliert
und war absolut eine voraussetzung für
den erfolg dieser maschinen heute
und damals in den letzten jahrzehnten
und wenn man das etwas
adäquater sehen will  So wie
hier
kann man
die Gewichte wirklich per Randomisierung einstellen
und dann kann man einfach
die Propagation und die Backpropagation starten
und die Gewichte werden angepasst
aber das geht viel
viel viel zu sehr ins Detail
weil es nur um die generelle
Idee geht  wichtig hier denke ich
und smolinski und das ist sehr
interessant
er ist ein
kognitionswissenschaftler, der mit der
idee beginnt oder der, sagen wir,
theoretisch in einem zusammenhang aufgewachsen ist, in dem diese
art von maschinen
als modell für
das gehirn gedacht wurde,
also geht
es um verstehen  das gehirn und
ein
modell für das gehirn zu haben, und diese art von ansatz stand oft im gegensatz zum ansatz zum verstehen von computern auf der basis der turingmaschine, aber smolinski versucht zwei dinge zu tun,
und das wird heute im fokus
stehen, denke ich
Auf der einen Seite versucht er
scharf zwischen den beiden
Ansätzen zu unterscheiden:
dem Digitalcomputer
und der Tyra-Maschine auf der einen Seite und
der Co. auf der anderen Seite  nktionistischen
Ansatz und dem künstlichen neuronalen
Netz, aber gleichzeitig versucht er
, ein ziemlich differenziertes Bild über die
Beziehungen zwischen diesen beiden Ansätzen zu
zeichnen, und ich denke, diese beiden Dinge, die die
Unterscheidung treffen und die verschiedenen
Ansätze zueinander in Beziehung setzen, werden der
Schwerpunkt unserer sein  Diskussion
von heute basierend auf diesem Text von Smolensky
, der im selben Jahr wie der
Text von Hubbard geschrieben oder mindestens im selben
Jahr veröffentlicht wurde wie der Text von Hubbard Typhoos, den
wir letzte Woche besprochen haben,
also freue ich mich sehr auf die
Diskussion,
danke  dir anna für deine kurze
einführung in die wissenschaft der neuronalen
netzwerke und
ich präsentiere jetzt die
schlüsselfragen für die heutige sitzung wie immer,
also zuerst
ist die frage, was versteht molenski
unter dem symbolischen und diesem
subsymbolischen paradigma, wie sind sie
Die technisch umgesetzte
zweite Frage ist, wie versteht Molensky
ihre Beziehung zueinander
und darüber hinaus zum Gehirn
und zur dritten Suche
Inwieweit konnektionistische Modelle als
rational bezeichnet werden können, könnten wir auch hinzufügen,
inwieweit sie als autonom bezeichnet werden können.
Vielleicht erinnern Sie sich, dass
er in dieser These nicht ganz explizit war,
aber wir sollten dieses
Problem wirklich von einem philosophischen
Standpunkt aus
diskutieren.  Ich werde die
Aufnahme jetzt stoppen und wir fahren dann
mit unseren Breakout-Sessions fort